right what i have right in front of me
is the khan academy measuring angles
measuring angles exercise i have a small
part of it in this screen right over
here and it's a pretty cool exercise
because it has this little virtual
protractor that we can use to actually
measure angles and i want to give credit
to the the person who built this
protractor because i think it's pretty
neat omar swan who was actually a high
school intern made this made this pretty
neat module and so in general when you
want to measure an angle what you want
to do is you want to put the center of
your protractor at the center of why i
should say the vertex of the angle or
you want to put the vertex of the angle
at the center of the protractor and then
what you want to do is either rotate the
angle or rotate the protractor in this
case we're going to rotate the
protractor you want to rotate the
protractor so that the zero angle or the
kind of the zero mark is at one of the
sides of the angle and the other side of
the angle is within the protractor so
let's try to do that so if maybe we
could put if we want to do that this
zero side should be at this side of the
angle so let's rotate it
let's rotate it that way
let me just keep rotating it
i can just keep it pressed that's better
all right
all right that looks about right so one
side is at the zero mark and then my
angle my other side or if this was a ray
it points to looks like pretty close to
the 20 degree mark so i will type that
in off the screen you don't see that and
that is the right answer and then we can
get another angle so let's try to
measure this one right over here so once
again place the center of the protractor
at the center at the vertex of our angle
we can place the zero degree the base of
the protractor at this side of the angle
so let's just rotate it a little bit
maybe one more time that looks about
right and the angle is now opening up
let's see the other side is pointing to
110 degrees so this is larger than 90
degrees it's also an obtuse angle the
last one was an acute angle this is
obtuse 110 degrees more than 90 degrees
let me type it in i got the right answer
let's do a couple more of these so once
again
put the center of the protractor at the
vertex of our angle
and now i want to rotate it
there we go and this looks like a
roughly an 80 degree angle not quite if
i had to be really precise it looks like
it's maybe 81 or 82 degrees but i'll
just go with 80 as my as my best guess i
got the right answer let's do one more
of these so once again
vertex of my angle at the center of my
protractor and then i want to put one
side of the angle at the zero degree and
i and i want to show you there's two
ways to do that you could do this
you could do
just this but this isn't too helpful
because the angle is now outside the
other side sits outside of the
protractor so you want the zero degrees
on the side so the other side is within
the protractor so let's keep rotating it
there we go and then our other side
opens up where you could say points to
70 degrees so this is an acute angle
right over here so it is 70 degrees so
i'll let you leave you with that oh look
i'm ready to move on the exercise tells
me and uh and and and now we can start
talking more things about angles now
that we know how to measure them